question who was the only southern
nevadan swimmer
to meddle in the olympic games oh boy
15 seconds probably less
john creech kind of looks like an
olympia five seconds
let's punctuate these answers
okay going from right to left ted
florindo
uh who is somebody i can't remember uh
a gentleman right gentlemen kind of a
poor effort
how about you christian all right i'm
gonna go for
ted florence all right
brian my first question is where's
john's tie yeah
and then here's my actual answer yes oh
wow
really good guess very creative very
close so why don't
you build this person yeah he won a goal
in a relay
yeah cody miller
it was indeed connor fields is an
olympian from
las vegas so that was much more educated
than
your competitors i went with the wrong
sport
i went bmx yeah you were way
yeah i think cody miller actually took
john's tie in his jacket too you know
what
it's fourth of july weekend it's
independent you're ready for a house
you're ready for a hot dog i'm actually
i'm surprised john's wearing a shirt
right now okay let's
pump the brakes hey how many push-ups do
you think john can do in a row
one thousand this is gonna be a hundred
thousand push-ups
yeah i got some cake for you can we give
you some cake
you can eat some cake you can't eat some
cakes this has been great
the answer was cody miller hold on who's
the better athlete john treacher cody
miller
i promise you it's cody miller hold on
are you bringing this over here all
right
we have music for john it's been an
awesome friday at 8 news now
there you go what is what is it
1776.
everybody clap it up
you can join us at newsnow.com along
with facebook and twitter
be sure to watch news now at 11.
happy 4th july